Are you looking for a great alternative to mid-journey? In this video I go
through 16 competitors and what I'll be doing is trialling three different
prompts, three different reference images and see how it looks in all 16
products. And we're going to use three images that I've used in the past. I've
created these in mid-journey. I've used them in my videos and with each of them
we're going to run them through the 16 AI art generators. We are going to need a
prompt. So what I thought I'd do is take each of the individual images and we'll
drag them straight into Dali 3. Once they're in Dali 3 we can actually
ask Dali 3 to tell us what the image is about. But I'll give it a little bit
extra context by giving it the original mid-journey prompt as well. And then
when we run it through Dali 3 we get a prompt like this. So in this particular
case it's create an animated illustration of a smiling 30 year old
blond man with eyeglasses. And then a bit later on it says the style should be
similar to modern animated illustrations with a clean and simple design. And what
we'll do is we'll take that prompt and the reference image and we're just going
to run it through all 16 AI art generators. So the first two we'll look
at is Night Cafe and Idiogram. Now Night Cafe has a nice clean user interface
where you can select different styles. Whereas Idiogram is really good at
doing symbolic art and idiograms. We've got two images here they're looking
pretty clean to me. Next we'll look at Open Art and Designs AI. So Open Art has
the ability to use multiple models. I think it has something like a hundred
different models that you can use. Designs AI can be used for images but it can
also be used for logos and videos as well. Next to our Blue Willow which is by
Linewire and a Dove Firefly. They're both producing really great images we would
expect that from a Dove but this Blue Willow product is also pretty good. I
better mention too that we have a Dove Firefly it's like canvas so you have the
ability to do a lot of other design tooling with that product. And that then
brings us on to Photor and Crayon. And Photor is an interesting one because
it's a graphics editing software and their implementation of generative art is
pretty good I think. Then we've got Crayon which I had a lot of trouble trying to
get good images from it. So this is the first time we've come across an AI art
generator that wouldn't compare to mid-journey but everything else has been
pretty good so far. Next we have Dream Studio and Imagine. And Dream Studio has
the ability to have moddable models as well that you can select from and
Imagine Art is a detailed illustration tool. Both of these are producing great
images. Next we're looking at Playground and Hotpot. Now Playground has advanced
editing features while Hotpot also has some editing capabilities. One of the
things I noticed with this particular image is that to me it didn't feel like
the illustration style that was described in the prompt but they're still
great images. The next two to look at is Lexico and Microsoft Copilot. And
Lexico in the past has been an AI art search engine. It's a great place to
get inspiration but they also have creation tools and we've used them here
and this is a tool I do want to deep dive into and there will be a video on
that. As for Microsoft Copilot it's essentially Dali 3. So whatever you're
looking for as well. The last two in the list are Worlds Apart. So we've got
Leonardo AI and Diffusion B. Now Leonardo AI has a lot of advanced tooling
and creativity that you can do within it. Diffusion B on the other hand is a
local computer implementation. So in my case it's running on the Mac and it
uses stable diffusion and I wasn't really able to get any good images out of
this particular model. So for the prompt of the 30 year old man creative
animated illustration we've got 16 different variations here and there are
plenty of great contenders to go up against mid-journey in this particular
case. What we'll do now is we'll move on to the next reference image and I'll give
you a little bit more detail about each of these applications as we go. We'll
start by dragging the reference image over into Dali 3. We'll also use the
mid-journey which had things like the style raw stylized 500. Now this won't
be able to be used effectively in the other art generators. So the generation
of the prompt is here. Creative realistic illustration of a woman in a 30
shown in side profile and we get all that information and this is what we're
going to feed into the 16 AI art generators. Moving over to the final
overview with this reference image we've again got a lot of great examples. Now
if there's a particular tool that you want me to do a deep dive in let me know.
Now I am going to do a two or three minute video on pretty much everything
that's here but there are a couple here that I'm going to use professionally with
my YouTube videos and they're the ones that I'm going to deep dive into. So let
me know which ones you're interested in and I'll do a video on them. Now the
first example we've got here is Night Cafe and Idiogram and both images are
pretty good in my opinion. Let's talk a little bit about Night Cafe. This tool
you can use stable diffusion or Dali 3. You've also got access to print on
demand and can select different art styles. I'll tell you more about Idiogram
when we look at the third reference image but moving on we can look at open
art and design AI. We've got interesting styles maybe the one from
Designs AI isn't as good as the mid-journey one but the open art one is
quite impressive. The thing about this particular tool is that apart from image
generation it's pretty good with anime characters and it's also got an image
upscaler. Moving on to Blue Willow and a dive firefly. Blue Willow is great as a
tool. It has many different styles that you can work from. It's got some tools
like background removers, blurs, 3D models and one of its key advantages is
that it's quick at generating images. Let's now have a look at Photor and
Crayon. Now Crayon like before doesn't really do a great job of generating
images but Photor is really interesting because not only is it
generating a good image but it's a really powerful tool. We've got photo
enhancement like upscaling background removal in painting. It's also got
realistic human face generation so it can do things like skin tones hair
accessories those sorts of features which are really hard to do with general
tools like mid-journey. It's got all the different styles of art that you might
want to do which you would expect from a lot of the image generations but it can
also do transforms from one style to another. Overall if you want image
generation but you also want image editing this might be a great tool to
look at. Moving on to Dream Studio and Imagine. We've got good images being
generated based on the prompt. Let's talk about Dream Studio. It's by stability AI
using the stable diffusion model. Now it's got all your texture image sort of
capabilities. It can also do image to image so you can take an image and
alter it and it's got capabilities like image upscaling. Looking now at
playground and hot pot so in this case the images are pretty good. The playground
has this really nice user interface and a very generous usage limit on a daily
basis. It uses different models it's got various tools and customizations and you
can also do image combinations combining images together. Moving on to
Let'ssica and Microsoft co-pilot. So Microsoft co-pilot which is Dali 3 we're
showing that here. Let'ssica is a search engine now it's got image generation
tools. It's got a lot of ability to customize things and look at the history
of images and adapt them over time. Moving on to the last two for the Japanese
girl. We've got Leonardo AI and Diffusion B and at this point I was nearly giving up
on Diffusion B but Leonardo is an incredibly powerful image generation
and AI generation tool. You've got capabilities like in-painting, out-painting
and magic erasers. You've got Control Net which gives intricate image guidance
and the real-time canvas allows you to make modifications to the image quickly
and easily. Now moving on to our last reference image which is the lion coming
out of the clouds. Now you might have noticed in the last section that I
talked a little bit more in detail about each of the image generators but I only
did one of them. Now I'll do the other half in this section. So with the image
we've dragged it into Dali 3. The original prompt was actually quite
simple. It was an an angel lion emerging from ash but with the image being
dragged into Dali 3 what we finally get is create a powerful and dramatic
illustration of a lion with angelic wings. Create a powerful and dramatic
illustration of a lion with angelic wings emerging from a cloud of ash. So
this is the prompt we're going to use for the 16 generators. So moving on to
Night Cafe and Idiogram. In this particular case I really love the image
that Idiogram has created. Night Cafe is not too bad. Now the thing about Idiogram
is it's a powerful tool. It's designed for both imagers and professionals.
It's got preset image stars 3d rendering. It's got community engagement and all
the sort of options editing that you would like to do. But additionally
it's got a diverse range of visual elements and icons and the other thing
that you can do with it is work with text. So you can combine text fonts,
colors and different styles with the generation. So let's have a look at
open art and designs AI. We've got pretty good images going on here. Designs AI
is an interesting tool. Developed by the Imagine group it's got a bunch of
makers. So it's got a text. It's got a logo maker, a video maker, a design maker
and speech maker. So something like the speech maker can be used for voiceovers.
and speech maker. So something like the speech maker can be used for voice
The other thing it's got are these pairers. So it's got font pair and color matcher.
overs. The other thing it's got are these pairers. So it's got font pair and
So an interesting range of tools with this particular product. Next we'll look
color matcher. So an interesting range of tools with this particular product.
at blue willow and a dove firefly. We've got two great images
Next we'll look at blue willow and a dove firefly. We've got two great images
going on here. Now a dove's going to be a really powerful tool moving forward.
So I guess its main competitor is Canva but it has the ability to integrate into
the rest of the adobe products. One of the things it's got is this ethical AI.
So it's all trained on images that it has the rights to. And then being a design
tool it has generative fill and expand. You can also do vector graphics with it.
Move on to photo and crayon. Now crayon has been a tool that I didn't get a
lot of success out of it. But it might still be a useful tool for you to use for
these reasons. It is a free tool and it has prompt predictions and suggestions.
And with a little bit of work you can get an image close to what you might want.
Next we'll look at dream studio and imagine art. And they're both producing great
images. Now imagine art is a pretty powerful tool. It's got different styles. Image remixing
and advanced configuration. It can also do background removal and in painting.
So we're looking at playground and hot pot again. And these are now becoming
leading contenders for myself. But let's talk a little bit about hot pot. So it's quite a
versatile tool that you can use for image generation. But you can also use it for photo
editing, headshots and avatars. One of the other things it can do is text writing.
So you can use it for your brainstorming and copywriting. And like tools like Canva or Firefly
it has templates that you can customize for social media. Moving on to Let's Secure and
Microsoft Co-Pilot. The Let's Secure image is really good. The Microsoft Co-Pilot for me is
something that you would use just the same way she would use Dali 3 within chat GPT.
Now if you're using Microsoft Co-Pilot you might not want to go any further than this.
And if you really want to see a great set of examples of mid-journey versus what
Microsoft Co-Pilot could do, you can check out the video that I did last year where I did 400
images, 50 prompts, 4 images per prompt for mid-journey and 4 images per prompt for Dali 3,
where you can get a good side-by-side comparison between these two different products.
And for the last two, Leonardo AI and Diffusion B. So the Leonardo image is pretty good.
The Diffusion B, the thing about this tool is that this image it's done is okay. And it's free,
it runs on your computer. So you have a lot of capability to produce images,
but it doesn't necessarily create the best results. But some of the tools that are built into it
include in-painting, out-painting and upscaling, and you can plug different models in. So if you
know what you're doing, you might be able to get this to a much higher level of capability
and just run it locally on your Mac computer in the case of Diffusion B. For Windows, I'm sure
there's a tool that does something very similar. So there's 16 great examples of the line coming
out of the ashes. We've got the lady in her house Japanese style, and we've got the man in his 30s,
yellow background, illustration style. Now, if there's any image generator that you want me
to explore, put a comment down below. Otherwise, like and subscribe. And I've got more videos in
the playlist here on Image Generation.